J'aimerais demander à quelqu'un qui puisse nous lire en août, voir les trois paragraphes de la confession de foi.
Avant qu'on fasse la lecture, peut-être qu'on pourrait revenir sur ces textes, car les thèmes d'aujourd'hui c'est
la supériorité de la nouvelle alliance par rapport à l'ancienne alliance.
On a fini la leçon dernière avec les deux dispensations de l'alliance sont en commun, l'ancienne et la nouvelle,
pour mettre toute cette emphase qu'il n'y a qu'une seule alliance des grâces.
Aujourd'hui on va se concentrer plus sur ce qu'il y a de différent et donc la supériorité de la nouvelle alliance.
Et donc ces passages et les buts même de la lettre aux Hébreux, c'est d'éprouver la supériorité de la nouvelle alliance.
Mais ces passages sont très clairs par rapport à ça et ils montrent déjà de soi-même plusieurs aspects.
Après avoir autrefois à plusieurs reprises et de plusieurs manières parlé à nos pères par les prophètes,
Dieu nous a parlé par les fils en ces jours qui sont les derniers.
Il a établi héritier de toutes choses et c'est par lui qu'il a fait le monde.
Ses fils qui est les rayonnements de sa gloire et l'expression de son être soutient toutes choses par sa parole puissante.
Après avoir accompli la purification des péchés, il s'est assis à la droite de la majesté divine dans les lieux très hauts,
devenu d'autant supérieur aux anges qu'il a hérité d'un nom bien différent de leur.
Donc quand on étudie la nouvelle alliance, on est devant vraiment l'éclat glorieux.
Et l'intentionnalité des dieux quand ils gèrent l'histoire, c'est clairement de nous proposer l'apothéose ou les climaxes eschatologiques.
Donc c'est presque impossible d'étudier les alliances sans avoir des impacts sur la eschatologie.
Et ici c'est intéressant car l'expression de l'auteur parle que déjà pendant l'incarnation du Christ, sa mort et sa récente ascension,
on était déjà devant les derniers jours.
Donc ça doit avoir forcément un impact envers la vision des fins des temps.
Si c'était déjà les derniers jours, on ne peut pas penser à certaines étapes où on deviendra anticlimatique,
ou climat, comment on dit ça en français ?
Anti-apothéose, comme si on avait des nouvelles oscillations, une période de reconstruction juive, terrestre, etc.
Surtout car l'expression s'asseoir sur les trônes signifie que l'œuvre est accomplie, totalement accomplie.
Les langages de s'asseoir c'est il est sur son trône.
Et c'est fini.
Le Christ a été manifesté dans la plénitude de sa gloire et d'ici vers l'avant tout ce qu'il a conquis s'accomplira inévitablement.
Et donc dans la nouvelle alliance, on est déjà dans la réalité du royaume du fils,
qui a été entronisé, qui est assis sous son trône, et toutes les choses doivent dire amène à sa volonté.
Et donc il est déjà en train de réjouir de l'héritage qu'il a conquis par sa mort et sa résurrection.
Et donc la transition c'est avant, on entendait parler du Christ de plusieurs reprises, de plusieurs manières,
mais maintenant le fils lui-même nous a parlé, étant lui-même le rayonnement de la gloire de Dieu.
Donc la manifestation suprême de la gloire de Dieu.
Donc c'est la même nature, l'alliance, ce sont les mêmes promesses,
c'est surtout une nouvelle manière de communiquer les choses
et de nous présenter l'aspect final et complet de ce que Christ avait nous fait en termes d'alliance.
Donc nous allons lire les trois paragraphes de la confession des foies,
et je vous fais ce rappel
que si vous voulez identifier l'ordre chronologique des choses,
ce qui est au troisième paragraphe de la confession
représente ce qui s'est passé d'abord.
L'alliance a été établie avant tout
entre les pères et les fils dans l'éternité avant la création du monde.
Et donc, les paragraphes 1, ensuite, ça montre la nécessité de cette alliance des grâces
une fois qu'on a échoué avec cette première alliance des vies,
l'alliance des œuvres, si vous voulez.
Donc le premier paragraphe, son intention, c'est de démontrer
qu'à partir de la chute, c'est impossible que Dieu mène un rapport avec l'humanité
sur aucune autre base qu'il ne soit la grâce.
Car une fois qu'on a échoué sur l'alliance des œuvres,
si Dieu devrait appliquer tout simplement sa justice,
ou si nous devrions dépendre de nos mérites,
on serait complètement condamné, impossible de ne mêner aucune relation avec Dieu
après la chute.
C'est l'objectif du paragraphe 1.
Le paragraphe 2 va démontrer
que non seulement, paragraphe 1, avec moi s'il vous plaît,
par nécessité, si Dieu continue l'histoire de l'humanité,
c'est par grâce, ok, paragraphe 1, paragraphe 2,
non seulement par nécessité,
car une chose qui est nécessaire n'oblige pas Dieu de les faire,
c'est nécessaire pour nous,
mais pas forcément pour Dieu.
Et donc, le paragraphe 2 nous montre
que Dieu, par des sens,
par son bon plaisir,
par la richesse de son propre caractère,
il a décidé d'agir avec nous
ou d'établir une nouvelle alliance,
une alliance des grâces.
Quelle est l'insistance confessionnelle
!
Et voilà pourquoi ils insistent sur le fait
que, par nécessité,
toute alliance des dieux établie avec l'homme
après la chute est une alliance des grâces,
et par des sens, c'est une alliance des grâces.
Pourquoi?
Car nous aurions pu être exposés
à, par exemple, une interprétation,
comme nous le sommes parfois,
de la loi mosaïque ou de l'alliance mosaïque,
comme en étant une alliance
en opposition à l'alliance des grâces.
Voilà l'intérêt de cette intentionnalité,
comme on verra,
l'impact vers la fin de cette laissante.
Mais bon, pour l'instant,
on se concentre sur la lecture
de ces trois paragraphes,
et nous allons faire juste attention
à ces aspects-là,
par rapport à la nécessité
de l'alliance des grâces,
au fait que Dieu a voulu
établir cette alliance des grâces,
et la manière dont Dieu l'a révélé
révéler les lans de l'histoire,
en révéler aussi un mystère derrière,
qui est l'effet que cette alliance
avait été établie avant la fondation du monde.
Ok?
C'est bon?
Donc, on va lire ensemble,
et on va passer à ce qui est nouveau.
La distance entre Dieu
et la créature
est si grande
que les personnes rationnelles,
qui pourtant doivent obéissance au créateur
pour les avoir façonnées,
n'auraient jamais obtenu la vie
comme récompense,
n'eût été une prondescendance
de la part de Dieu,
qui ne s'est plus
à exprimer par le moyen de l'alliance.
Par rapport à 2.
Bien plus,
puisque l'homme s'est placé
sous la malédiction de la loi
par sa chute,
il a plu au Seigneur
de faire une alliance de grâce,
dans laquelle il offre aux pécheurs
la vie et le salue par Jésus-Christ,
requérant de la foi en lui
pour être sauvé.
Il y promet,
en outre,
de donner son esprit saint
à tous ceux qui sont
destinés à la vie éternelle,
afin de les rendre désireux
et capables de croire.
Cette alliance est révélée
dans l'évangile,
tout d'abord à Adam,
dans la promesse du salut
par la prostérité de la femme,
et par la suite,
progressivement,
jusqu'à sa révélation complète
dans le nouveau testament.
Elle est fondée
dans la transaction
d'alliances éternelles,
entre le père et le fils,
concernant la rédemption des deux.
Ce n'est que par la grâce
de cette alliance
que tout membre
de la prostérité d'Adam,
déchu,
a jamais été sauvé
et a obtenu la vie
ainsi que la bienheureuse
d'immortalité,
puisque maintenant,
l'homme est complètement
incapable d'être accepté
par Dieu
dans les conditions
qui étaient valables
pour Adam
dans son état d'innocence.
Ok.
Donc là,
à saisir,
à se rappeler
ces trois aspects
que nous allons
continuer d'aborder aujourd'hui.
Donc,
par nécessité,
il faut que l'alliance
établie après la chute
soit une alliance des grâces.
Dieu a voulu les faire,
il l'a fait,
donc de manière très claire
en étudiant la Bible,
nous les voyons,
et un mystère glorieux
est révélé.
Donc,
la manière dont Dieu
a révélé
l'alliance des grâces
a été glorieuse
car c'était une révélation
progressive
à partir
de plusieurs alliances
dans l'Ancien Testament
et on peut arriver
à des conclusions logiques
à partir de là
à propos des alliances.
Donc,
les conclusions,
donc là,
c'est par quoi
ce qu'on a fait.
Donc,
on a commencé
à s'habituer,
en fait,
respecter la manière
dont Dieu a révélé
et donc,
on a étudié
les principales alliances
qu'on trouve
dans l'Ancien Testament
et on a constaté
à chaque étape
qu'il s'agissait
de quelque chose
de gracieux.
OK ?
Et ensuite,
on est passé
à considérer
l'alliance des grâces
dans l'Ancien Testament
avec plus de conviction
car on a vu
que chaque alliance
était une alliance des grâces
et on a compris
que c'était une seule
alliance des grâces
qui était révélée
de manière progressive.
on a fait usage
de quelques textes
du Nouveau Testament
pour arriver aussi
à cette conclusion.
Et donc,
ensuite,
on est passé
à identifier
quelques conclusions
doctrinales.
Donc là,
on peut affirmer
qu'il y a
une seule
alliance des grâces
qui est
cette alliance des grâces
elle est révélée
ou elle est plutôt
administrée
dans deux grandes administrations
donc deux économies
ou deux dispensations
l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
Ancien Testament
et Nouveau Testament
et donc
ce qui est important
à saisir
c'est que
dans l'Ancien Testament
cette alliance
des grâces
elle a été révélée
par plusieurs alliances
dont certaines
étaient subsidiaires
aux autres.
Donc là,
quelle était
l'alliance principale
en termes
des formalités
explicites
dans l'Ancien Testament
si vous vous rappelez.
C'est l'alliance
avec qui ?
Abraham.
Ok, super.
Quel chapitre ?
De Genèse ?
15.
Ok.
Et donc là,
quelle était
l'expression
ou les termes
pour
pour établir
une alliance
ou
faire une alliance ?
C'était
de couper
une alliance.
Vous vous rappelez de ça ?
Ça, c'est très important.
Donc, ce n'était pas
la première fois
une alliance
était identifiable
car depuis Genèse
lorsque
les proto-évangiles
sont prononcés
donc l'inimitié
entre la descendance
du serpent
et la descendance
de la femme
c'était déjà
une alliance établie
que Dieu
était en train de faire
et elle est clairement
identifiable.
En même temps,
elle est formalement
établie
avec Abraham.
Ok ?
Et donc,
vous vous rappelez
il y a un couloir.
C'est pour ça
que dans les mariages
on fait un couloir
ça vient
de laos.
C'est la conscience
d'un serment
d'une alliance
établie
et on devrait
avoir la même
compte en fait.
Si on ne tient pas
les voeux
quelque chose
comme ça
devrait arriver
à nous.
Et donc,
les animaux
divisés.
Donc,
par exemple,
quand on pense
par exemple
à certaines propositions
qui prennent
l'alliance
mosaïque.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc,
l'alliance
mosaïque.
Et qu'ils veulent
suggérer
que comme elle met
beaucoup d'emphase
sur les punitions
et sur les lois
et les obligations
on est devant
une alliance
des lois,
des oeuvres,
une républication
des alliances
des oeuvres,
on devrait se rappeler
en fait
que depuis
l'alliance
mosaïque,
on avait
déjà
des animaux
déchirés
et presque
des conditions
proposées là-bas.
Sauf que c'est
Dieu lui-même
qui passe tout seul
pour dire
si l'une des parties
ne prend pas
sa position
ou ne tient pas
les termes,
ça va retomber
sur moi.
OK ?
Et donc là,
c'est clairement
Dieu passe seul
pour nous rappeler
de cette réalité.
Et donc,
Abraham a été
l'alliance principale
et à partir de là,
même l'alliance
mosaïque
qui vient après,
elle sera
subserviente
ou subsidiaire
à cette alliance.
Et donc,
l'alliance mosaïque,
elle est aussi
remplie des grâces
comme on a déjà vu
à cause
de plusieurs révélations,
le niveau
de révélation
par rapport
à Christ.
Et donc,
ensuite,
on est passé
à déterminer
les trois
vérités principales
qu'on doit traiter.
Donc,
on doit
affirmer
qu'ancienne
alliance
et nouvelle
sont
une seule
alliance
des grâces.
OK ?
C'est la même
alliance
sous
deux administrations.
Donc,
l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance,
c'est la même
alliance des grâces.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
OK ?
Et donc,
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire
par là ?
Que
toutes ces alliances
qui étaient établies
avec Abraham,
Moïse,
Adam,
Noé,
etc.,
c'était une manière
de révéler
l'alliance des dieux
avec l'homme
avec une richesse
progressive
pour qu'on comprenne
chaque fois plus
comment cette alliance
va véritablement
arriver
à sa maturité,
à sa plématurité.
qui sera celui
qui viendra
et qui va accomplir
ce qu'il faut
pour qu'on puisse
réjouir pleinement
de cette alliance.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc,
toutes ces alliances-là,
elles étaient en train
d'être utilisées
par Dieu
comme des moyens
de révélation
progressive
du besoin exact
qu'on aurait
véritablement
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
quand il arriverait.
Donc,
bien sûr qu'avant
que Christ n'arrive,
on n'arrive pas
à saisir
toute la compréhension,
mais une fois
que Christ vient
et qu'il éclate,
c'est clair qu'on peut
comprendre
comment on pourrait
voir Christ
dans chacune
de ses alliances
représentées
par les couloirs
des animaux déchirés
ou par,
quand on revient
à l'arche de Noé,
comme on a considéré
en fait,
protégé par Christ
et les déluges
qui tombent sur lui.
Et donc,
à chaque fois,
on pourrait revenir
et trouver
qu'il était
les descendants
promis à la femme
qui va écraser
la tête du serpent
et son talon
serait blessé.
Mais on n'aurait
pas la capacité
d'identifier
Christ à la croix
si on était
dans leur dispensation.
Si on était
Adam,
on pourrait croire
que Dieu va pouvoir
en descendant
qu'il viendra
et il va régler
les problèmes.
Mais on ne savait pas
exactement
de quelle manière.
Quand est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une idée
plus claire
de quelle manière
Christ doit régler
ses problèmes ?
C'est à partir
du moment
où on a la loi mosaïque
où on a
toutes les lois
sacrificielles,
les animaux
qui doivent souffrir,
la loi restaurée
en fait,
l'image des dieux
qu'on devrait avoir
et qu'il devrait être.
Donc,
tout cela,
ce sont des moyens
des grâces
pour qu'on comprenne
exactement la manière
parfaite dont il doit vivre,
comment il doit mourir
et toutes les images
du tabernacle
ou du temple
qui font référence
au tabernacle céleste.
Et donc,
comment ne pas voir
l'alliance mosaïque
comme une alliance
des grâces
si elle nous apporte
la plus grande information,
la plus grande révélation
et la manière exacte
dont Christ devrait
vivre parfaitement
la loi à notre place
et souffrir la pollution
en tant qu'agneau
sacrificiel.
Et donc,
c'est la même alliance.
comment on a confirmé
cette vérité ?
Je vous rappelle
quelques points.
Donc,
il s'agit d'une seule
et même alliance
et donc,
on a vu
les points
qui sont en commun
entre les deux alliances.
C'est la même
grande promesse.
Quelle est la promesse
principale
si vous vous rappelez ?
Je serai votre Dieu
et vous serai mon peuple.
Donc,
c'est les plus grands privilèges
qu'un être humain
puisse réjouir.
C'est des pouvoirs
appelés Dieu,
mon Dieu
et de savoir
qui Dieu se dirige
en nous
en disant
c'est mon peuple.
C'est mon fils,
c'est ma fille.
Et donc,
c'est la même promesse.
On a vu
plein des passages
bibliques
dans l'Ancien Testament
et dans les Nouveaux Testaments
qui montrent clairement
que c'est la même
promesse principale.
Réconciliation
avec Dieu.
Ensuite,
c'est la réjouissance
des mêmes bénédictions.
On a vu plusieurs textes
dans l'Ancien Testament
et dans les Nouveaux Testaments
qui montrent
que nos frères
et sœurs
dans l'Ancien Testament,
les vrais
croyants spirituels,
il y avait beaucoup
de non-croyants
même d'entre
les peuples juifs,
mais la réalité
c'est que tous ceux
qui sont décrits
comme étant
véritablement dans la foi,
ils réjouissaient
des mêmes bénédictions
qu'ils ont réjoui.
donc voilà,
la joie du salut,
la sanctification,
la pureté.
Donc même s'ils ne réjouissaient pas
dans les mêmes niveaux
d'intensité
qu'il y a nous
dans la Nouvelle Alliance,
c'était la même nature,
les pardons des péchés,
la conviction
du pardon des péchés,
etc.
Et donc,
ils ne sont pas
qu'ils pardonnés
au moment où Christ
est là,
en train d'être crucifié
à la croix
et que l'œuvre
est accomplie.
Non,
c'était bien sûr
basé sur les sacrifices
futurs de Christ
qui pouvaient être pardonnés,
mais l'anticipation
de ces pardons,
de la régénération,
de la justification,
c'était des bénédictions
qu'ils ont pu réjouir.
Donc Abraham,
il a cru en Dieu
et cela lui a été
amputé à justice.
Et donc,
la justification
était déjà en réalité
la sanctification,
l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit,
même si l'intensité
n'était pas la même.
On a vu plein de passages
qui montrent
ces mêmes réalités.
Ensuite,
c'est les mêmes évangiles
prêchés,
ok ?
Donc,
c'est les seuls
et les mêmes évangiles
donc écraser la tête
du serpent
et avoir
les talons blessés.
On pense tout de suite
directement à la croix
aujourd'hui.
Mais eux,
ils ne pouvaient pas voir ça.
Mais c'est les mêmes évangiles.
Donc,
il viendra un descendant
de la femme,
un seul,
qui va faire
le travail qu'il faut faire.
Ok ?
Donc,
la même chose,
on voit
par plusieurs autres manifestations,
même par les pâques,
les tabernacles,
les sacrifices,
les temples.
Et donc,
tout l'Ancien Testament,
il prêche.
Donc,
Galate 3,
8,
il nous dit,
« Et l'Écriture,
ayant vu que Dieu justifie
par la foi les gentils,
annonça auparavant
la bonne nouvelle à Abraham. »
Donc,
Dieu lui-même,
il a proclamé
l'évangile à Abraham.
« Toutes les nations
seront bénies en toi. »
Donc,
c'est les mêmes évangiles
dans l'Ancien Testament,
les mêmes évangiles
dans le Nouveau Testament.
C'est la même église
spirituelle.
Donc,
c'est les mêmes
peuples de Dieu.
Donc là,
c'était l'un des points
les plus importants
à traiter,
en ayant un grand impact
aussi sur les positions
par rapport à la fin des temps.
Donc,
il y a un seul peuple
des dieux,
les chrétiens
de l'Ancien Testament
et les chrétiens
du Nouveau Testament,
les croyants
de l'Ancien Testament
et les croyants
du Nouveau Testament.
Donc,
c'est les mêmes peuples.
l'Israël non converti,
il n'est pas
la vraie descendance
d'Abraham.
Le Nouveau Testament
traite ça
de manière explicite.
OK ?
C'est possible encore
que des juifs,
des personnes
d'éthines juives
se convertissent
et il y aura
un nombre de juifs
convertis
à la fin des temps.
Mais la réalité,
c'est qu'ils sont,
ils seront
ou ils sont
les peuples de Dieu
tant qu'ils aient
la foi.
OK ?
À partir du moment
ils auront manifesté
la foi.
Mais il n'y a pas
une histoire parallèle
encore préservée
pour favoriser Israël
encore car
la position
climatique
d'Israël
ou l'apothéose
arrive
lorsqu'il,
dans la plénitude
du temps,
née d'une femme,
née sous la loi,
les Christs arrivent.
Les descendants
sont arrivés.
Et là,
la chose peut être
accomplie
dans la direction
de tous les peuples.
donc,
c'est la même
église spirituelle
et on a lu
plein de passages
importants.
Et les mêmes
et seuls moyens
d'appropriation
de salut.
Donc,
la foi
dans l'Ancien Testament
et dans le Nouveau Testament,
c'est toujours
les moyens
d'appropriation
et de participation
dans l'alliance
des grâces.
Personne ne participe
à l'alliance des grâces
sans la foi,
sans croire
que Dieu
va tenir ses promesses
ou qu'il a tenu
ses promesses
en Jésus-Christ.
les mêmes
et seuls médiateurs
ultimes,
donc les fils
des dieux
incarnés
à la fin des comptes,
elle est seule
et même médiateur
de toutes ces alliances
qui étaient typifiées,
Christ était typifié
dans toutes ces autres alliances
où il a été mentionné
de manière
moins claire
ou plus claire.
Donc,
par exemple,
c'est le descendant,
donc c'est référence
à Christ,
les vrais médiateurs
ou lorsqu'il a promis
à Abraham
que toutes les nations
seraient bénies
dans ton descendant
et en Galacte,
Paul va dire
il a promis
à Christ lui-même,
à son descendant
et donc l'alliance,
elle est établie
avant tout
avec Christ.
Ça,
on va y revenir plus tard.
Et donc,
aujourd'hui,
pour apporter
quelque chose de nouveau,
c'est la supériorité
de la nouvelle alliance.
C'est qu'il y a
des différends
entre les deux
dispensations
et donc,
dans l'Ancien Testament,
tout représente,
même parfois
de manière faible
comme ombre
ou type
et tout pointe
envers Jésus-Christ.
OK ?
Donc,
on a des allusions
préfiguratives
à Christ.
Par contre,
dans la nouvelle alliance,
c'est Christ lui-même
qui est là
en train de remplir
la signification
de l'alliance.
Et donc,
dans l'Ancien Testament
ou dans la sienne alliance,
tout pointe envers Christ
et dans la nouvelle alliance,
c'est Christ lui-même
qui est au centre
et qui va remplir
toutes les ombres
et tous les signes
qui représentaient
l'ancienne alliance.
Donc,
la première chose
ou le premier aspect,
c'est que la Bible,
surtout dans le Nouveau Testament,
montre de manière
très claire
la supériorité
de la nouvelle dispensation
en termes d'alliance.
Donc,
on commence par là.
Quand on pense
notamment,
tout simplement,
à la notion
d'administration,
donc on vous rappelle
très bien,
quand on a cette expression
dans le Nouveau Testament
qui nous parle
d'une nouvelle alliance,
on aurait pu
être tenté
à arriver
à la conclusion
que ce soit
quelque chose
radicalement différent
ou substantiellement différent
ou essentiellement différent
de l'ancienne alliance.
Si nous voudrions
avoir une interprétation
dure,
littérale,
on arriverait
à cette conclusion.
Mais la question
qu'on doit se poser,
surtout car on voit
clairement beaucoup
des choses en commun
entre les alliances,
c'est qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de nouveau
dans la nouvelle alliance ?
Pourquoi est-elle appelée
nouvelle alliance ?
Et donc,
quand on va chercher
à définir
ce qu'il y a de nouveau
dans la nouvelle alliance,
c'est possiblement
le travail
les plus important
à faire ?
Et peut-être
qu'on n'aurait pas
cité des divisions
par rapport
à certaines positions
de l'impact
de notre compréhension
des alliances
par rapport
au baptême,
par exemple,
si on était
plus critérieux
à définir
rien qu'à les critères
pour savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de nouveau
dans la nouvelle alliance.
À quoi se dirigent
les termes
nouveaux ou nouvelles
dans la nouvelle alliance ?
Non, ça c'est très important.
Pour certains,
la nouvelle alliance,
c'est tout simplement
l'arrivée
de la substance
ou l'arrivée
du Christ
et parfois,
ils veulent suggérer
que l'alliance,
elle est presque
totalement nouvelle.
Et voilà pourquoi
ils vont mettre
l'emphase sur la rupture
entre l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance.
Et pour d'autres,
c'est qu'il y a de nouveau
va être un peu plus léger
par rapport à ce qu'il y a
vraiment de nouveau.
Ils vont insister plus
sur la continuité
de l'alliance
qu'est sur la rupture.
Et donc,
comment définir
ce qu'il y a de nouveau
dans la nouvelle alliance ?
Donc,
l'exercice à faire,
c'est d'abord
de chercher
les textes bibliques
capitaux.
Donc,
où est-ce que dans la Bible
on trouve
l'expression
nouvelle alliance ?
Donc,
on a Jérémie,
Ézéchiel,
d'autres passages.
Ensuite,
comment la nouvelle alliance
est explicitement abordée
dans les Nouveaux Testaments ?
Donc,
nous venons de traiter
en lisant actes
certains aspects clairs
de la nouvelle alliance.
Donc,
l'insertion de tous les païens,
juifs et païens
dans la même position
devant Dieu.
On a pu comprendre
comment les Saint-Esprit
viennent pour sceller
la nouvelle alliance.
Donc,
on voit clairement
que c'est la même alliance
des grâces
qui arrive à sa conclusion
et qui a,
au niveau d'intensité,
évidemment,
mise en emphase.
Donc,
la participation
des croyants,
la liaison
entre les signes
de la nouvelle alliance
et la réalité
de la présence
du Saint-Esprit.
Et donc,
quand on essaye
de chercher
à comprendre
comment la Bible,
elle décrit
dans ses narratives
du Nouveau Testament,
actes,
et la manière
dont les textes bibliques
des lettres
du Nouveau Testament
vont décrire
ce qu'il y a de nouveau
dans la nouvelle alliance,
comme Hébreu,
par exemple,
qui est le livre
par excellence
à cet égard,
nous allons noter
que ce qu'il y a
de nouveau
dans la nouvelle alliance
n'est pas forcément
l'alliance en soi,
mais la réjouissance
de la participation
dans cette alliance.
C'est surtout
combien les peuples
de l'alliance
du Nouveau Testament
peuvent réjouir
de ses promesses
et ses privilèges
qui ont été promis
et réjouis
de manière faible
dans le Nouveau Testament.
Donc,
c'est nouveau
dans l'essence
de pleine révélation,
pleine manifestation
et pleine réjouissance.
Ce qui était
un peu plus faible,
ombre,
mais c'est notamment
ce qui est nouveau,
c'est l'administration
de l'alliance.
Ce n'est pas forcément
l'alliance
car elle est
la même alliance.
Ce qui est nouveau,
c'est la réjouissance,
c'est l'administration,
c'est qui est aujourd'hui
notre médiateur direct.
dans quelle mesure
gérer soit
les conséquences
de cette Nouvelle Alliance.
Est-ce que
ça fait partie
de la Nouvelle Alliance
l'attente
envers quelque chose
qui va encore se passer
ou
ce qui est plus
en phase
de la Nouvelle Alliance,
c'est la concrétisation
de tout ce qui a été promis
et qui est déjà là.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc, bien sûr,
on n'est pas en train
de parler de l'impact
de la fin des temps
eschatologique
finale,
mais on est en train
de parler
de l'inauguration réelle
et effectif
de la Nouvelle Alliance.
C'est à ça
que se dirigent
les textes bibliques
envers la Nouvelle Alliance
dans le Nouveau Testament.
Donc, la supériorité
de la Nouvelle Alliance
en termes d'alliance,
en termes des pactes,
et par là,
c'est notamment,
directement,
les médiateurs
plus excellents
qui est devant nous.
Donc, Hébreu 3,
versets 4 et 6
nous dit le suivant,
« Car toute maison
est construite
par quelqu'un,
mais celui qui a construit
toutes choses,
c'est Dieu.
Pour Moïse,
il a été fidèle
dans toute la maison
des dieux
comme serviteur
pour rendre témoignage
de ce qui devait
être annoncé.
Mais Christ l'est
comme fils
sur sa maison
et sa maison,
c'est nous,
pourvu
que nous retenions
jusqu'à la fin
la ferme confiance
et l'espérance
dont nous nous glorifions. »
Et donc,
la maison,
c'est l'engagement
des maisons.
À quoi ça fait référence ?
Ça, c'est très important.
À nouveau,
même pour votre vision
par rapport
à la fin des temps.
Quelle est la maison
dont on parle ici ?
Les temples,
les tabernacles
dans le cas de Moïse,
mais les temples
plus tard avec David.
Et donc,
les tabernacles,
pourquoi on est en train
de parler des maisons ?
Et là,
il dit clairement
la maison
sommes-nous
aujourd'hui
dans la Nouvelle Alliance.
C'est clair
que dans l'illustration
de l'Ancienne Alliance,
Dieu venait
avec Sanuée
et faisait une visitation
apparente,
faible,
parfois saisonnière
ou temporelle.
Ok ?
Temporaire.
Mais,
une fois que
le Saint-Esprit
est envoyé,
nous sommes
la maison des dieux
et nous sommes
les temples des dieux.
Donc,
cet accomplissement
qu'on verra
spirituel
est déjà là.
Donc,
c'est la réjouissance.
il n'y a pas
de l'espace
dans une compréhension
biblique
de la Nouvelle Alliance
d'être dans la dynamique
d'une attente encore
de quelque chose
qui va encore s'accomplir.
Car nous sommes
la maison.
Qui est l'époque
de l'Alliance
dans le Nouveau Testament ?
Ce sont ceux
qui sont habités
par les Saint-Esprits.
C'est évident.
Et donc là,
on voit de manière
très claire
la supériorité
du médiateur.
Car Moïse,
il était un médiateur
d'une relation
à distance
avec Dieu.
Donc voilà,
si vous vous nourrissez
encore
en espoir
d'un rétablissement
d'un temple
littéral,
comme la gloire
du deuxième temple.
La gloire du deuxième temple,
c'est la résurrection
du Christ.
C'est les corps
spirituels du Christ.
L'Église.
Mais c'est très important.
Ici,
il est en train
de dire
cette relation
à distance
représentée
par les tabernacles,
par les temples,
c'était à distance.
Pourquoi ?
Car les peuples
ne pouvaient pas
rentrer dans les
sangs des sangs.
Il y avait besoin
de plusieurs types
de médiations
jusqu'à arriver
à la présence
des dieux.
Et maintenant,
le Saint-Esprit
est envoyé
l'habitant.
Comment pourrions-nous
désirer rétrécir,
revenir en arrière,
mener en relation
avec Dieu,
guidé par un temple
qui veut donner
des distances
envers Dieu ?
Et donc ici,
la maison
typologique,
la ombre
de cette relation
libre avec Dieu,
s'était médiée
ou gérée
par Moïse.
Il était
les dispensateurs,
il était
l'entendant
de cette maison.
Mais là,
nous sommes
dans une maison
où Christ lui-même
est les médiateurs.
Les médiateurs
plus excellents.
Chapitre 8,
verset 6,
mais maintenant,
il a obtenu
un ministère
d'autant supérieur
qu'il est les médiateurs
d'une alliance
plus excellente
qui a été établie
sur des meilleures
promesses.
Donc une autre chose
évidente,
donc là,
les focus,
c'est les médiateurs.
Christ,
elle est médiateur
excellent
d'une alliance
excellente.
Et là,
ça fait partie
de la nouvelle alliance
les promesses
qui sont réjouies
d'une manière
encore plus
intense,
les meilleures promesses.
Galate 3,
19 et 20,
pourquoi donc la loi,
elle a été donnée
ensuite à cause
des transgressions
jusqu'à ce qu'ils vendent
la postérité
à qui la promesse
avait été faite.
Donc ça,
c'est très important.
C'est ça,
l'aspect
le plus mystérieux.
Car même
lorsqu'il est
Paul en train
de faire référence
à cette alliance
établie avec Abraham,
il est en train
de dire ici
de manière explicite
que la promesse
avait été faite
pas à Abraham,
mais à son descendant,
à Christ.
Donc l'alliance,
ultimement,
avait été établie
avec ces médiateurs
qui ont été toujours
les seuls vrais médiateurs,
mais qui,
dans la nouvelle alliance,
se présentent
comme médiateurs
effectifs
de cette nouvelle alliance.
et donc,
pardon,
la postérité
à qui la promesse
avait été faite,
car elle a été promulguée
par des anges.
Donc là,
c'était pour montrer
combien faible
était l'alliance
établie avec Moïse,
car la loi a été donnée
par les anges
au moyen d'un médiateur.
Or,
le médiateur n'est pas
médiateur d'un seul,
tandis que Dieu
est en seul.
Donc là,
c'est une comparaison
entre cette alliance
intra-trinitaire
qui est établie
pour nous,
donc Christ,
notre représentant
pour nous,
mais c'est une alliance
établie entre Dieu
et Dieu.
Dieu est en seul.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Mais cette alliance
qui avait été établie
par Moïse,
c'était typologique
d'une alliance
plus excellente,
car on a un médiateur
plus excellent.
Et il y a aussi
voilà,
d'autres passages
qui montrent
l'excellence du Christ
en tant que médiateur.
Donc la nouvelle alliance
est là,
un médiateur
plus excellent.
Donc là,
là,
la notion
des proximités,
elle est très importante.
Surtout,
à nouveau,
l'impact
de la compréhension
de la nouvelle alliance
envers les baptêmes.
Comment suggérer
qu'ils pourrions
faire partie
de cette nouvelle alliance
dont les médiateurs
s'est présenté,
dont les médiateurs,
il est là,
dont la connexion
avec Dieu,
elle est déjà
effective et immédiate
à tous ceux
qui font partie
de cette alliance.
nous ne pourrions
plus ou pas
suggérer
que dans les cadres
de la nouvelle alliance,
on puisse participer
des personnes
qui sont encore
dans l'attente
de quelque chose
où la proximité
avec le médiateur
n'est pas là.
Donc ça,
ça fait partie
de cette emphase biblique.
Donc le niveau
des révélations
du plan de rédemption,
c'est un autre aspect.
Donc les plans
de rédemption
dans l'ancienne alliance,
ils étaient
progressivement révélés.
OK ?
Sauf que les plans
de rédemption
dans la nouvelle alliance,
ils ont été
pleinement révélés.
Donc on n'a plus
à quoi attendre
en termes d'instruction
pour savoir
quels sont
les plans
de rédemption
de Dieu.
Donc là,
on a vu
et on a considéré
plusieurs types
dans l'Ancien Testament,
mais la Bible
a dit explicitement,
Christ lui-même
en disant
en Jean chapitre 14,
je suis l'échemin,
la vérité
et la vie.
On n'est pas encore
dans l'attente
de marcher vers un chemin
où la vérité
sera révélée
de manière plus claire.
Donc Christ,
il vient,
il se présente,
il dit,
nul ne peut venir
au Père à part moi.
C'est clair
que lui,
il est le vrai médiateur,
il est le vrai moyen
par lesquels
cette alliance
est véritablement
affirmée.
Et donc,
Jean chapitre 1,
verset 17 à 18,
car la loi
a été donnée
par Moïse,
la grâce
et la vérité
sont venues
par Jésus-Christ.
Donc par là,
l'objectif des gens
n'est pas
de nier la réalité
qui est grâce
était présente
dans les ministères
de Moïse,
mais l'emphase
de Moïse
était sur la loi
afin que
cette loi
qui va nous condamner
à tous
puisse retrouver
la grâce,
donc cette grâce
des condamnations
de la part de la loi
qui nous amène
certainement à Christ.
Et donc,
un Christ,
grâce sur grâce.
Donc c'est plutôt
le niveau d'intensité
que nous voyons là.
La vérité
et la grâce
sont venues
par Jésus-Christ.
Personne n'a jamais vu Dieu,
les fils uniques
qui sont dans les sains du Père,
c'est lui
qui l'a fait connaître.
Donc la révélation pleine.
Donc on a pu
connaître Dieu
de manière
véritablement
limitée,
dans l'Ancien Testament,
mais la révélation
maximale
des dieux
et du plan de rédemption
vient avec Jésus-Christ
qui vient
du sang du Père.
Première lettre
de Pierre,
chapitre 1,
verset 10 à 12.
Les prophètes
qui ont prophétisé
touchant la grâce
qui vous a été réservée,
ont fait
de ces saluts
l'objet
de leur recherche
et de leur investigation.
Vous l'en sondez
l'époque
et les circonstances
marquées par
l'esprit
de Christ
qui étaient en eux
et qui attestaient
d'avance
les souffrances
de Christ
et la gloire
dont elles seraient
suivies.
Il leur fut révélé
que ce n'était
pas pour eux-mêmes
mais pour vous
qu'ils étaient
les dispensateurs
de ces choses
qui vous ont annoncé
maintenant,
ceux qui vous ont
prêché l'Évangile
par les Saint-Esprits
envoyés du ciel
et dans lesquels
les anges
désirent plonger
leur regard.
Donc même
les anges
avaient l'intérêt
de connaître
et contempler
la pleine révélation
de ces plans
de rédemption.
Donc même Daniel
il écrit en disant
j'ai entendu
j'ai vu
mais je n'ai pas compris
mais Dieu m'a dit
écrit.
Et donc à plusieurs reprises
même les prophètes
n'avaient pas
la compréhension pleine
des choses
qu'ils étaient en train
ils étaient en train
de prononcer pour nous.
Mais une fois
qu'il Christ vient
tout devient clair.
mais pendant les processus
les choses n'étaient pas
très claires pour eux.
Hébreu 11
39 et 40
Tout cela
à la fois desquels
il a été rendu témoignage
n'ont pas obtenu
ce qui leur était promis
Dieu ayant en vue
quelque chose
de meilleur pour nous
afin qu'il n'est parvence
pas sans nous
à la perfection.
Donc c'est clair
que la nouvelle alliance
elle est marquée
par une révélation
beaucoup plus excellente
pleine du plan
des rédemptions
des dieux.
Mais non seulement
la révélation
du plan des rédemptions
comme
l'accomplissement
complet
de la rédemption
en elle-même.
OK ?
Donc point 3
c'est les niveaux
non seulement des révélations
mais les niveaux
du développement
du plan des rédemptions.
OK ?
Donc on a lu
Hébreu 1 à 3
donc autrefois
elle nous a parlé
par les prophètes.
Dans ces derniers temps
il a parlé
par les fils
et donc il est
après avoir fait
l'expiation
des péchés
il est monté
à la droite
de la majesté divine
dans les lieux très haut.
Donc là c'est pour dire
tout est accompli.
Il n'y a rien encore
à atteindre
en termes
d'accomplissement
conditionnel
pour qu'on puisse
se réjouir
pleinement
de cette alliance.
Il a tout payé
et il a vécu parfaitement
il est mort à la croix
et donc il est assis
c'est complet.
OK ?
Donc la nouvelle alliance
elle est marquée
par la plénitude
ou la complétude
le fait
que c'est complet
cette réalité.
Et donc non seulement
on est devant
voilà
la révélation
mais l'accomplissement.
Donc c'est
c'est
c'est langage mystérieux
biblique
qui nous dit
que nous sommes
un Christ.
et donc un Christ
c'est-à-dire
on est inséré
en lui par la foi
on est membre
de son corps
et lui
en tant qu'il représentant
de l'humanité
devant la présence
de Dieu
en ayant cette double nature
Dieu et homme
donc les plans
de rédemption
pleinement accomplis
nous permet
de réjouir
pleinement
de cette coparticipation
dans la nature divine
merveilleuse
glorieuse
car nous sommes
en lui
et voilà pourquoi
Colossiens 2
9 et 10 nous dit
car en lui
habite corporellement
toute la plénitude
de la divinité
ça c'est
un mystère
glorieux
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
c'est que
c'est Dieu
fils
deuxième personne
de la trinité
il a assumé
la forme humaine
et lorsqu'il a
assumé la forme humaine
il a fait
les miracles
des miracles
comme dit
les mystères
des mystères
que Dieu
dans sa plénitude
habite
corporellement
dans un corps humain
pour être
notre représentant
et pour qu'en lui
nous soyons
aussi coparticipants
de cette nature divine
vous avez tout
pleinement en lui
qui est l'échef
de toute domination
et de toute autorité
voilà la réalité
des chrétiens aujourd'hui
les plans de rédemption
est plans
et nous nous sommes
trouvés
notre vie
est cachée
en Jésus Christ
Jean 1 14
et la parole
a été faite
chère
et elle habitait
parmi nous
pleine de grâces
et de vérité
et nous avons
contemplé sa gloire
la gloire
une gloire
comme la gloire
du fils unique
venu du Père
et donc là
les plans de rédemption
n'est pas tout simplement
une révélation progressive
de la manière
par laquelle
Dieu nous sauvera
ok
car c'est important
pour nous
de comprendre
la vie parfaite
que Christ doit vivre
la mort
qui doit souffrir
à notre place
mais plus que de révéler
les moyens
de rédemption
la rédemption
elle vient personnifier
et nous nous retrouvons
en Christ
c'est cette révélation
des Christ
en fait
par les plans de rédemption
qui devient plus glorieux
ok
c'est presque synonyme
Christ
et rédemption
à cet égard
et nous nous trouvons
en lui
par la foi
donc sans contredit
les mystères
de la piété
est grand
Dieu a été
manifesté en chair
vous comprenez
l'emphase
que je suis en train
de mettre
c'est pas tout simplement
les plans de rédemption
ont été révélés
c'est Dieu
s'est manifesté
en chair
pour nous sauver
c'est plus glorieux
c'est beaucoup plus glorieux
justifié par l'esprit
vu des anges
prêché aux nations
cuit dans les mondes
reçus dans la gloire
donc
un autre aspect
de la nouvelle alliance
qui fait
qu'elle soit
plus excellente
c'est qu'elle est
entièrement
spirituelle
la nouvelle alliance
est
bien sûr
qu'elle va
comprendre
va englober
dans sa restauration
pleine
vers les futurs
glorieux
la chair
mais aujourd'hui
les prémices
de la réalité
de la réjouissance
dans la naissance
n'est pas d'être
focalisé
à la prospérité
temporelle
comme
la manière didatique
Dieu voulait
dans l'Ancien Testament
utiliser Israël
donc s'ils avaient
un roi pieux
Israël prospérait
s'ils avaient un roi
un pie
Israël souffreraient
et quelle était
la raison de ces choses
c'était de didattiquement
lier la piété
à la vraie rédemption
à la vraie
prospérité
pourquoi
les temples
devraient être
si beaux
si riches
car ils représentaient
la gloire céleste
et donc
une fois
qu'Christ
vient
inaugurer
et déclencher
d'une fois pour toutes
la réalité
de la résurrection
donc l'emphase
de l'apôtre Paul
en roman
c'est de nous dire
les Saint-Esprit
l'homme antérieur
s'est rénové
chaque jour
nous allons contempler
que nous sommes
vivants
ou ressuscités
surtout car
spirituellement
on a été régénéré
et nous pouvons attester
que notre
sanctification
progresse
même si
l'homme extérieur
se corrompte
même si on est
susceptible
à la persécution
si on est
susceptible
aux maladies
on va voir
que même ces choses-là
sont en train
de jouer
pour que notre
homme antérieur
soit renouvelé
et qu'on puisse
progresser
spirituellement
donc l'emphase
c'est la plénitude
déjà
de la restauration
du déclenchement
spirituelle
et certitude
que comme lui
il a été le premier
né d'entre les morts
nous allons
sémer
ces corps
corruptibles
et nous allons
raccolter
ou cultiver
ramasser
ces corps
glorifier
et donc
c'est très important
de voir
que la dynamique
pour la nouvelle
alliance
est la prospérité
avant tout
spirituelle
et la compréhension
que tous ces types
et ombres
de l'Ancien Testament
jouaient
plutôt
pour communiquer
les réalités
radicalement
spirituelles
c'est pas pour
qu'on reste
dans la nouvelle
alliance
focalisée
sur la possible
prospérité
terrestre
ou d'Israël
ou quoi que ce soit
donc
Hébreu
chapitre 9
laisse ça très clair
donc la première
alliance
avait aussi
des ordonnances
relatives aux cultes
et les sanctuaires
terrestres
ok
et donc
quelle est
l'intentionnalité
de l'auteur
c'est de dévier
l'attention
tout comme Christ a fait
en début d'acte
c'est pas pour vous
de savoir
les temps
ou les époques
pour restaurer
les rômes terrestres
d'Israël
allez donc
fête des disciples
de toutes les nations
mon royaume
est à propos
de l'évangélisation
de la croissance
spirituelle
de l'église
ici c'est la même chose
la transition c'est
ne serait pas
accroché
à l'importance
du sanctuaire
terrestre
et donc
quand on saute
au verset 10
et qui avec
les aliments
les beurrages
et les diverses
ablutions
étaient des ordonnances
charnelles
imposées seulement
jusqu'à une époque
des réformations
mais Christ
est venu
comme un souverain
sacrificateur
donc qu'est-ce qu'il est
en train de communiquer
dans l'ancienne alliance
ces choses étaient
didatiques
elles étaient temporaires
c'était jusqu'à ce que
la vraie restauration arrive
mais Christ
est venu
comme un souverain
sacrificateur
des biens
à venir
est-ce qu'il est en train
de parler des biens
à venir
de la restauration
du temple
du tabernacle terrestre
ou est-ce qu'il est en train
de parler du bien
à venir
en termes
de spiritualité
car
et là
tout de suite
car il a traversé
les tabernacles
plus grands
et plus parfaits
est-ce qu'il est en train
de parler
d'un tabernacle physique
ou est-ce qu'il est en train
de parler
du sanctuaire céleste
c'est évident
plus grand
et plus parfait
qui n'est pas construit
des membres d'hommes
c'est-à-dire
qui n'est pas
de cette création
et il est entré
une fois pour toutes
est-ce qu'on peut attendre
en lisant ce langage
qu'il va entrer ailleurs
dans un autre tabernacle
s'il est entré
dans ce tabernacle
sanctuaire céleste
une fois pour toutes
dans les lieux très sains
non avec des sains
des boucs
et des veaux
mais avec son propre sang
ayant obtenu
une rédemption
éternelle
vous comprenez
c'est fini
la distanciation
entre Dieu et nous
Jean 4
21-24
Jésus dit à la femme
crois-moi
leur vient
où
ce ne sera
ni sur cette montagne
à Jérusalem
que vous adorez
les pères
vous adorez
ceux qui vous ne connaissez pas
nous adorons
ceux que nous connaissons
car les saluts
viennent des juifs
mais leur vient
elle est déjà venue
où les vrais adorateurs
adorons les pères
en esprit
et en vérité
car ce sont là
les adorateurs
qui les pères
demandent
Dieu est esprit
et il faut que ceux
qui l'adorent
adorent en esprit
et en vérité
quelle est la didatique
ici
pour ce qui concerne
la transition
des alliances
c'est que
la dispute
était sur des lieux
terrestres
d'adoration
et notamment
l'importance
du temple
ou du tabernacle
dans ces cas là
et donc
à Jérusalem
il n'y a plus
besoin
d'un temple
car l'esprit
est venu
la connexion
est directe
Hébreux 10
verset 1
la loi
en effet
n'a qu'un nombre
de bienvenirs
et non les réels
même des choses
elle peut jamais
par les mêmes sacrifices
qu'on offre
continuellement
chaque année
rendre parfait
ceux qui s'approchent
2ème pierre 1
par lesquels
il nous a donné
ses divines
et précieuses promesses
!
afin que vous
deveniez
participants
de la nature divine
ayant échappé
à la corruption
qui est dans les mondes
par la convoitise
Romains 8
9 à 11
pour vous
vous n'êtes pas
dans la chair
mais dans l'esprit
si du moins
l'esprit de Dieu
habite en vous
mais si quelqu'un
n'a pas l'esprit
de Christ
il ne lui appartient pas
et si Christ
est en vous
les corps
il est vraiment
à cause du péché
mais l'esprit
est vie
à cause de la justice
et si l'esprit
de celui
qui a ressuscité
d'entre les morts
habite en vous
celui qui a ressuscité
Christ
d'entre les morts
donnera aussi
la vie
à vos corps mortels
par son esprit
qui habite en lui
Ephésiens 1
béni soit Dieu
les Pères
de notre Saint Jésus
Christ
qui nous a bénis
de toutes sortes
de bénédictions
spirituelles
dans les lieux
célestes
Jésus leur répondit
Jean 2
détruisait
ses temples
et en 3 jours
je les relèverai
les juifs dirent
il a fallu 46 ans
pour bâtir
ses temples
et toi
tu les relèveras
en 3 jours
mais il parlait
du temple
de son corps
Apocalypse
je ne vis
point
des temples
dans la ville
car les seigneurs
Dieu
tout puissant
et l'agneau
en sont
les temples
ça devrait être
suffisant
à cet égard
la réalité
spirituelle
de la nouvelle
alliance
ensuite
un autre élément
c'est la portée
globale
par descendivant
et par
la didactique
de l'ancienne
alliance
qui était
ethnique
ou nationale
donc il y avait
un rôle
pour Israël
pour être
l'école
élémentaire
d'une relation
avec Dieu
d'alliance
par contre
la réalité
du Nouveau Testament
c'est une réalité
d'une alliance
par descendivant
qui va s'étendre
à toutes les nations
donc je n'aurai pas
le temps
de lire
tous les passages
je peux vous envoyer
après
mais
on a plein de passages
bibliques du Nouveau Testament
qui montrent
clairement
que la vraie
descendance
d'Abraham
n'est pas la descendance
de la chair
mais c'est la descendance
de la foi
d'Abraham
donc les vrais
Israël des dieux
et donc
les murs
de séparation
qui a été détruit
et donc
on a
cette dynamique
dans la Nouvelle Alliance
que ce sont
ceux
de la foi
ok
de manière très explicite
et emphatique
ceux
de la foi
de la réalité
présente
de la foi
de toutes les nations
un autre aspect
de ce qui a
de nouveau
plus excellent
dans la Nouvelle Alliance
c'est que
l'état final
plan et complet
est là
lorsque l'ancienne alliance
était préparatoire
et provisoire
ok
je sais que j'ai déjà mis
cette emphase
en direct
sur d'autres points
donc
les mêmes textes
avec lesquels
on a commencé
hébreu 1
donc autrefois
plusieurs reprises
de plusieurs manières
nous a parlé
par les prophètes
etc
mais là
dernièrement
par les fils
donc c'est définitif
c'est complet
hébreu 10
12 à 14
après avoir offert
un seul sacrifice
pour les péchés
s'est assis
pour toujours
à la droite
des dieux
attendant désormais
jusqu'à
que ses ennemis
soient mis
pour restreindre
ses pieds
car par une seule offrande
il a rendu parfait
pour toujours
ceux qui sont sanctifiés
hébreu 11
39 et 40
tout cela
voilà
on a déjà lu
les textes
en fait
ils ne pouvaient pas
parvenir à la perfection
sans nous
et donc c'est la réalité
de ce qui est
déjà complet
et on n'a plus
des emphases préparatoires
dans le Nouveau Testament
ça c'est très important
ça a aussi de l'impact
par rapport à notre position
crée de baptiste
on ne considère pas
comme participants
de l'alliance
et de la nouvelle alliance
ceux qui sont
en phase préparatoire
envers la foi
qui pourrait un jour venir
c'est la réalité
de cette foi
qui est déjà là
car l'emphase
de la nouvelle alliance
il n'y a pas de sens
d'avoir un symbole
appliqué
pour représenter
une alliance
qui met l'emphase
sur ce qui est
déjà là
et qui n'est pas
dans l'attente
de quelque chose
futur
ok
et le septième point
et dernier
c'est
les déversements
de Saint-Esprit
de manière
voilà
universelle
pour tous les chrétiens
dans une intensité
profonde
donc les croyants
de l'Ancien Testament
nous savons
qu'ils étaient aussi
sous l'influence
de Saint-Esprit
qu'ils étaient aussi
habités par les Saint-Esprit
dans une certaine mesure
car ils avaient besoin
d'avoir
la régénération
la foi
qui est en don
des dieux
la répentance
la justification
par contre
c'est clair
que l'une des
influences principales
dans le Nouveau Testament
ça peut être mystérieux
pour nous
de découvrir
de quelle manière
les Saint-Esprit
opéraient
dans l'Ancien Testament
nous savons
que par l'enseignement
clair
du Nouveau Testament
il n'y a pas
de régénération
et de vraie conversion
si les Saint-Esprit
n'opèrent pas
et donc c'est clair
qu'il opère
dans l'Ancien Testament
on a des passages
publiques dans l'Ancien Testament
qui nous les montrent
clairement
c'est clair
qu'il y avait
un certain type
messianique
où les Saint-Esprit
opéraient
d'une manière spéciale
sur certains types
du Christ
mais les Nouveaux Testament
nous montrent clairement
que les Saint-Esprit
est répandu
ça parle
d'une espèce
de générosité
à tous les chrétiens
donc tout cela
donc Abraham
votre père
s'est réjoui
devant mon jour
il a vu
et il était
dans la joie
donc ça pointe
envers
quelques évidences
donc en Galate Paul
il va parler même
du Saint-Esprit
et il va citer
tout de suite Abraham
pour suggérer
que le Saint-Esprit
il était là
à l'origine
de la foi d'Abraham
mais dans le Nouveau Testament
c'est clair
que c'est la Pentecôte
elle-même
qui est interprétée
comme l'inauguration
de la nouvelle alliance
effective
la descente du Saint-Esprit
qui vient nous sceller
et nous donner
le privilège
de réjouir
d'une intensité
d'une conviction
que ceux
de l'ancienne alliance
n'avaient pas
et voilà pourquoi
le baptême
est associé
aussi au ministère
du Saint-Esprit
comme représentation
du travail
de l'oeuvre
intérieure
du Saint-Esprit
donc voilà pourquoi
c'est très important
pour nous
de voir l'impact
de l'emphase
du Nouveau Testament
sur les participants
de la nouvelle alliance
donc ces passages
en actes
il est important
car
l'interprétation
de Pierre
est que
le Saint-Esprit
est en train
de descendre
sur ceux
qui croient
déjà
et c'est important
car il va établir
ses conditions
car il est devant
un public juif
si c'est
vraiment une promesse
automatique
pour les enfants
des juifs
ils pourraient
tous recevoir
le Saint-Esprit
directement
mais
Pierre
il va dire
de manière explicite
répentez-vous
et soyez baptisés
et vous recevrez
la promesse
donc il conditionne
la réception
du Saint-Esprit
quelque part
ou l'identification
de la réception
du Saint-Esprit
par la répentance
et la foi
et à partir de là
il dit aussi
la promesse
est pour vous
pour vos enfants
voilà
la promesse
elle reste là
pour vous
et pour vos enfants
sous la condition
pour participer
de la nouvelle alliance
pour réduire
la nouvelle alliance
que vous vous répentez
et croyez
et que vous croyez
et que vous soyez baptisés
et à partir de là
ça s'applique aussi
à tous ceux
dont Dieu
appellera
de toutes les nations
donc
on va s'arrêter
ici
avec juste
une conclusion
pardon
donc là
on a vu
ce qu'il y a
des différents
des communs
l'illustration
que Lloyd-Jones
propose
c'est un enfant
qui arrive
à l'âge
de maturité
c'est la même nature
ok
c'est la même personne
mais
elle est
en pleine force
dans une pleine sagesse
ok
si on imagine
un homme parfait
et un enfant
un enfant
il peut réjouir
des mêmes choses
mais il peut
ne pas tout comprendre
vous voyez
donc l'ancienne alliance
elle était
comme
la révélation
du plan de rédemption
et la réjouissance
de la rédemption
comme si c'était encore
dans son enfance
l'école élémentaire
mais quand on arrive
dans la nouvelle alliance
c'est comme si on était
en pleine maturité
en réjouissant
de la pleine force
de ces révélations
de cette réalité
et donc
pour juste
conclure
avec
cette emphase
particulière
du paragraphe 3
de la confession
qui nous dit
en fait
que
cette alliance
des grâces
ces alliances
de l'ancienne alliance
et l'alliance
des grâces
dans sa totalité
elle est en fait
la révélation
d'un mystère
et les mystères
c'est
qu'avant tout
et surtout
cette alliance
avait été
établie
entre les pères
et les fils
ok
et donc
ça c'est la chose
la plus glorieuse
quand on pense
aux alliances
car c'est là
où on voit
qu'on était
véritablement
au long de l'histoire
ou les longs de l'histoire
en train de voir
une révélation
progressive
et glorieuse
d'une vérité
qui a eu lieu
dans l'éternité
passée
avant même
que les mondes
ne soient créés
et donc
il a pu
à Dieu
les pères
à donner
au fils
en peuple
une épouse
si vous voulez
et
toute l'histoire
de l'humanité
a été planifiée
en parfaite harmonie
avec la justice
de Dieu
la santé
la sagesse
de Dieu
mais l'histoire
a dû se dérouler
exactement de la manière
dont elle s'est déroulée
pour qu'on puisse
comprendre
au maximum
de nos forces
pour que l'église
de l'Ancien Testament
et du Nouveau Testament
puissent
grandir
dans cette école
alimentaire
apprendre
élémentaire
pardon
apprendre progressivement
à aimer les Christs
exactement
de la manière
dont Dieu
avait planifié
pour qu'on puisse
chérir
notre époux
notre mari
Christ
dans sa pleine perfection
conscient
de notre total besoin
pour qu'on puisse
être intégré
dans la nature
divine
co-participant
à la nature divine
une seule chair
si vous voulez
c'est membre
du corps de Christ
mais en même temps
co-participant
de la famille
des dieux
et donc
c'était nécessaire
à partir du moment
où Dieu a décidé
établir ses pactes
avec son fils
ce n'était pas quelque chose
de nécessaire impératif
dans l'être des dieux
si vous voulez
mais à partir du moment
où Dieu a voulu
que Christ puisse avoir
une relation
si intime
avec son église
qu'il devienne
un médiateur
d'une alliance
excellente
maritale
et donc c'est totalement
glorieux
de contempler
en fait
que toutes ces révélations
là
ce sont les déroulements
d'un pacte
ou d'une alliance
qui a été établie
avant tout
entre les pères
et les fils
et donc à partir
du moment
où les fils
s'est accordé
avec les pères
avec ses pactes
il était
donc
obligé
il a volontairement
entré dans ses pactes
et donc
à partir du moment
où il va assumer
cette alliance
il va assumer aussi
les conséquences
les termes
il doit honorer
cette alliance
des vies cassée par Adam
il doit traiter
avec les résultats
de la chute
il doit se porter garant
de tous les dévois
et conditions
de l'alliance des grâces
donc là
les couloirs
c'est Christ
qui va
subir tout ça
et pour
accomplir
cette alliance
des grâces
il doit
voilà
c'est une doctrine glorieuse
l'incarnation
du fils des dieux
mais même
les miracles
de l'incarnation
est quelque chose
qui est à service
de l'accomplissement
de cette réalité
et donc à partir du moment
où le fils dit
oui au père
je veux racheter
pour moi
une épouse
il doit
donc
s'engager
à devenir
le deuxième Adam
pour nous
prendre la nature humaine
en tant que notre
représentant légal
et s'écharger
de toutes les saintes exigences
des dieux
sur l'humanité
et donc
à partir du moment
on comprend
l'alliance
établie entre les fils
et les pères
c'est là
que nous sommes
en mesure
et ça c'est la prochaine doctrine
qu'on va étudier ensemble
dans les prochains chapitres
la prochaine doctrine
c'est la doctrine
la christologie
à propos du Seigneur Jésus Christ
c'est à dire
l'incarnation
du fils des dieux
et là
les bons cadres
pour s'approcher
de cette glorieuse doctrine
de contempler notre époux
c'est de savoir
qu'il est devenu
cher
homme
notamment pour pouvoir
remplir toutes les exigences
et cette alliance des grâces
de la vie